I'd like to introduce you to a
particularly powerful paradigm for
thinking called Bayes rule back in the
Second World War the then Governor of
California Earl Warren believed that
japanese-americans constituted a grave
threat to our national security and as
he was testifying as much to Congress
someone brought up the fact that you
know we haven't seen any signs of Sutter
fuge from the japanese-american
community
and warned respondent that ah this makes
me even more suspicious this is an even
more ominous sign because that indicates
that they're probably planning some
major secret timed attack a lot Pearl
Harbor and this convinces me even more
that the japanese-americans are a threat
so this pattern of reasoning is what
sustains most conspiracy theories you
see signs of a cover-up well that just
proves that I was right all along about
the cover-up if you don't see signs of a
cover-up well that just proves that the
cover-up runs even deeper than we
previously suspected Bayes rule is
provably the best way to think about
evidence in other words Bayes rule is a
formalization of how to change your mind
when you learn new information about the
world or have new experiences and I
don't think that the math behind the
math of Bayes rule is crucial to getting
benefit out of it in your own reasoning
or decision making in fact there are
plenty of people who use Bayes rule on a
daily basis in their jobs statisticians
and scientists for example but then when
they leave the lab and go home they
think like nan Batian is just like the
rest of us so what's really important is
internalizing the intuitions behind
Bayes rule and some of the general
reasoning principles that fall out of
the math and being able to use those
principles in your own reasoning after
you've been steeped in Bayes rule for a
little while it starts to produce some
fundamental changes to your thinking for
example you become much more aware that
your beliefs are grayscale they're not
black and white that you have levels of
confidence in your beliefs about how the
world works that are less than 100% but
greater than 0% and even more
importantly as you go through the world
and in
counter new ideas and new evidence that
level of confidence fluctuates as you
encounter evidence for and against your
beliefs also I think that many people
certainly including myself have this
default way of approaching the world in
which we have our pre-existing beliefs
we go through the world and we pretty
much stick to our beliefs unless we
encounter evidence that's so
overwhelmingly inconsistent with our
beliefs about the world that it forces
us to change our mind and you know adopt
a new theory of how the world works and
sometimes even then we don't do it so
the implicit question that I'm asking
myself that people ask themselves as
they go through the world is when I see
new evidence can this be explained with
my theory and if yes then we stop there
but after you've got some familiarity
with Bayes rule what you start doing is
instead of stopping after asking
yourself can this evidence be explained
with my own pet theory you also ask well
would it be explained better with some
other theory or maybe just as well with
some other theory is this actually
evidence for my theory